out an incredible voyage that's being
undertaken by a former British Marine
Carter Evans is following the story 56
year old Steve sparks and his rowing
partner McGowan are on an epic journey
they've been making their way across the
Pacific for the past three months now
they're battling powerful winds and
waves from hurricane lane yeah it's been
quite thrilling but also accept some
scary at times especially because you
can't see the former British Marine lost
most of his sight during a diving
accident in his 20s I was doing really
well in my career it all came to an
abrupt end and I've never had the chance
just put myself if you like back on the
map reinvented myself so we set out to
become the first blind person to row
across the Pacific relying on his
partner to describe what's happening
around them and it was a whole new
experience for me and to experience
through description the wildlife and the
elements what it can offer you the good
and the bad now just about 160 miles
from the finish line officials insisted
the team drop anchor and wait for the
worst DePass it's gonna be a rough ride
huh definitely one definitely to tell
the grandchildren about the boat is
battered they've lost three of their six
ores but sparks dry British sense of
humor remains firmly intact
on Friday he texted okay so far mate
experiencing mild thrashing at present
had worse but this will do they're
hoping to land on Oahu by Tuesday or
Wednesday for CBS this morning Saturday
Carter Evans Los Angeles fact that he
didn't give up says it all about this
guy okay so far me